for the first time in New York City I
was in a cab that did the 360 it's very
romantic and and actually everything
else buses cars trucks they were all
doing the same thing at the same time so
it's like slow motion Walt Disney anyway
because it means that we are what we are
here tonight but but a special warm
welcome on a cold night to our visitor
is an architect from Cape Town but also
from New York in their classic kind of
New York way kind of worn somewhere grew
up here goes back does good a lot of
good and I guess that's what I'm super
interested in the the the michela lab
starts in 2004 the studio and it already
of course has this word lab in there so
don't implying that there's a kind of
experiment that it's not a rate not
simply a studio but there's some kind of
research in some kind of a project and
this project seems to involve tasting an
idea about about public interaction and
that the purpose of architecture is for
the kinds of interaction that it makes
possible but especially I'm interested
in the way in which you think about the
interaction is not the interaction that
the architect designs for now but what
interaction might take place when the
current user and the current architect
have ever gone and also the fact that
they're there this kind of statement
about creating the possibility of future
exchange so like what you call legacy
like kind of the legacy of anarchy so
you're kind of designing for for legacy
that that that's done in the context of
culture of fear so basically everybody
is too nervous to get together in public
space because you might catch an idea or
a disease or
or whatever and that leads to your kind
of argument that good design as a basic
human right and that its design itself
goes from being sort of a virtuous
addition or criticism or or supplement
to what's considered the basic
conditions of social exchange it's
actually considered as a as a kind of
crucial requirement of social exchange
and so on and I think you do that in
your work but you also do that almost
diplomatically by by working at the
World Economic Forum on the global
agenda for design and all of that such
as oozing virtue I think there was not a
more virtuous person ever spoke in this
room and and also an elegant person and
and I think that the the there is also
something about the way the world is
moving now I other than in the 60s to be
virtuous men also not to be beautiful
and in the sixties they tried out the
idea that there that and this applies to
architecture that an ethically
responsible architecture would also be
an elegant architecture and I think the
the current generation of architects
seems to me is super interesting in the
refusal of any need to choose between
our ethical responsibility elegance
professional success technical
sophistication and so on so we really do
live in a very different mindset and I
think your work it's very much coming
from that mindset and its really very
stimulating to us that you and Mary are
working together in the design studios
and therefore as always it's nice to
hear outside of the studio what you're
thinking so very much welcome to the
school
thank you very much I'm a bit
overwhelmed by the extent of research
you've done on me clearly the web is a
very good device okay I must let me
start by saying the wave structure the
presentations with the short sort of
paper which talks to you know my
position on architecture and then
basically a series of projects taking a
quite a light cut sort of level the idea
being that it should be a provocation so
that questions can emerge from the crowd
in terms of the actual solutions so let
me start esteemed colleagues students
and friends I thank you for this
opportunity to share a few ideas an
anthology as it were which speaks to the
nature of architecture as an act of
agency and urgency in the South African
context I hold that architecture is a
contingent act mediated by contradictory
and promiscuous forces which can
conspire to diminish the potential of
space and the built environment and yet
equally sets the condition for new and
multi village readings of morphology if
we conceive architecture is more than a
receptacle of program space elaborated
skin but as catalytic nodes in a
physical and existential terrain
architecture can assume political
dimension and was the politics of
aesthetics and ethics and place can
merge into a seamless intentionality
this syntax forms a code a language in
which the message transcends form but as
a tactical conversation of being knowing
and not knowing such intention allottees
cannot be calibrated outside of the
specificity of context and the
indeterminacy of human relationships
where architecture is a dialogue between
place and technology intellectual
capital Edith ology power and
vulnerability this metabolism this
delicate dance of design seeks to find a
syncopated rhythm and eclectic
harmonization between the imagined and
the real between the physical certainty
of today and the promise of tomorrow
this mode of praxis foregrounds a
situatedness of theory as a tool and
adaptive informant of intervention and
experimentation but when located in the
fragile invulnerable terrain of scarcity
and addressing developmental state needs
often requires bold humility and often
selfless regard South Africa has a hyper
terrain of flux in which binary and ray
of light reading is readily emerged but
the complexity of your socio-cultural
condition is in its resistance to fixed
coordinates of meaning and possibilities
we're not dissimilar to Heisenberg's
uncertainty principle definitions of
architecture and Africa are viscous
temporal and tangential this heterotopic
landscape is chimera like in nature it's
defined to monoculture and visual
readings of syntaxin space architecture
under such conditions must confront
undiscovered vertices of meaning myth
function and morphology and embrace
contradiction if authenticity and truth
to space place and time can emerge the
morphological implications of this
epistemological Odyssey represents an
undiscovered and perhaps alternate
terrain in the global context of
architectural discourse where
architecture engages with homogeneous
culture and dominant cultural narratives
I would argue that it's contextual
purposes simplified through the various
public's that encounter the edifice that
have been historically empowered to read
the text of the architecture and
therefore find resonant and II mainland
meetings the enigma ladies Africa is in
its heterogeneous and contradictory
landscapes of excess and poverty
cultural misogyny and untapped abundance
and legacy of intentional fractured
development and this enigma is the
foundation for a contested terrain in
which the nature of an appropriate
architecture defies simplistic Cartesian
matrices of meaning and perspective but
rather a mutable landscape of innuendo
double Anton's hybrid spatial strategies
which equally affirm and deny the
creolization of contemporary african
culture South Africa in particular
occupies this queasy
tableau that we're urbanism architecture
and landscape can't conspire to support
the emergence of meta-narratives around
which society can Co here and with it
the promise of a morphology which
transcends form but reflects and
channels the unspoken submerged vectors
of being and subverts the subservience
of the subaltern into dignified cultural
actors my work is the task to translate
this complexity into simple elegant
humanist solutions that are an effective
dialogue with their context i noticed
that i put spring over there and I think
that's not in tune with what nature has
intended outside so forgive me on that
on that particular score also you see
this mouse works I'll start just by
giving you an image that maybe people
don't necessarily associate with South
Africa and Kate alma Cape Town is a
place which has stark if not startling
beauty in some parts architectural but
you know the sort of natural context
it's an amazing place to be in but at
the same time just outside of the proof
of your town it's it's it stands against
extreme poverty degradation and extreme
levels of contrast and I think what this
what this does it makes the position of
the architect quite contentious because
it's very easy to decide which world and
one wants to operate in and that's why I
make this point about relationship
between the politics and ethics of the
architect and the role of the agent
because I've made a conscious decision
to try and splice conditions where a
degradation context can benefit from the
role of the architect and actually avoid
the the easy route of doing glamorous
and sexy buildings for the well-heeled
and the rich Cape Town is and i just
thought i'd show you this diagram is a
very distorted city you know it has a
central city core along the side and
essentially a periphery that wraps
around its edge and this is a direct
product of apartheid planning in which
the city core was essentially a space of
white privilege with a dormitory
settlements along
edge and you begin to see that this has
an implication because depending on
where one situates a project or the sort
of relationship to to to the to the
urban planning strategies of the day one
can intervene productively or
unproductively so i'll take you through
projects at different scales first off
you know with the with World Cup I was
actually contacted by Budweiser last
year as part of a national competition
to design a trophy for the world cup and
the strategy was was that I developed
was actually quite quite a simple one I
first decided to critique the sort of
history of trophies and let's say
recognition of success ranging from the
wreath to the amphora to their to the
urn the chalice the traditional trophy
and what was quite consistent all of
these is this notion of a cup or
something that actually holds no liquid
or fluidity a sense of a receptacle and
for me I said if we're going to make an
African trophy I think it needs to do
two things I think it needs to respond
to let's say an African sensibility
about how to express success but more
importantly the issues of the day need
to come to the fore so through a very
quick presentation we looking at you
know beadwork and craft work and also
looking at the bottle itself I i decided
to recycle the bottles and actually use
them as part of the strategy for for the
trophy so you know in short you know you
have one bottle you know and you you
empty it then you've got the glass more
drinking produces numerous empty bottles
and I was fascinated with the glass and
actual cap so what I did essentially was
proposed that we would recycle all of
the glass crushed them into into beads
recycle the caps to form a sort of
meshed let's call it sort of web and
that putting these together one would
deconstruct the notion of the trophy so
that it on the one hand you have a sort
of firm exoskeleton from the aluminium
but in the inside this sort of spongy
soft and almost pliant sort of internal
skin and the sort of formal language of
this i decided to steer away from there
the metaphor
cup but said that I would look at sort
of sensual forms relating to dance of
music and natural phenomena and proposed
this actually formed for budweiser the
proportions of the actual trophy were
structured according to the number of
games there was an issue about the
weight of the current trophy so these
ones could not be heavier than them and
the intention was that there would be 64
of these trophies and at the end of
every world cup match the man of the
match would be given this trophy this
was supposed to be done through cell
phone competition throughout the world I
explained to Budweiser that the
logistics of doing an on a live cell
phone competition globally would
probably defeat them and unfortunately
he did with this with this competition I
was actually told that I had one but
apparently the sea or budweiser said it
didn't look african enough and i found
that to be quite interesting that he
knew more about an African aesthetic and
I did the winning the winning a trophy
was actually a drum very clever and and
unfortunately it was it was never
manufactured but I thought would be
quite an interesting way to show you how
that notion of aesthetics and also how
one can question fundamentals of what is
the trophy and try and articulate
something different under diff and in
terms of a jump in scale a lot of my
work as I think as Marcus mentioned
works beyond the architectural scale I
get involved with institutional
structures I get involved with
essentially establishing organizations
because in South Africa we've we're at
the beginnings of our democracy so the
type of conditions which allow for
architecture to emerge as often not
there so this particular project
essentially was I was asked to do some
eco lodges using local materials in a
very sensitive forest but quite
importantly we had to use homeless
people to actually build the building
and so on so the notion of having a sort
of strong intellectual capital and how
you detail the buildings becomes
transformed when you realize you're
dealing with people who've never even
held a piece of wood before so the
exercise here
in part it's responding to context to
wind and so on but i think the real
hypothesis in journey is what type of
architectural language is appropriate
when the people making buildings are at
an almost zero skill level and this had
various implications for the language of
the building the fact that i had to used
found materials all sides to actually
construct the building so there wasn't
the luxury of me using the sort of
typical materials that one would expect
but i think what was very successful
about the project and that stone wall by
the way we had to demolish it three
times to teach people how to put a stone
wall together but it seamlessly fits
into its context and they were sensitive
trees that had to be avoided so the
design methodology of this project was
very much one of sensitivity one of calm
and I'm quite proud to say that through
this project we trained almost 60
different people homeless people who now
know how to make a door who now know how
to make a window and they're able to
take those skills elsewhere so the
impact of this project is less about its
form and more about its it's a mode of
becoming and these are just some some
other shots I expect this will be
published before the end of the year if
everything works out well very simple
low-tech sort of solution but the
detailing was quite a rigorous and
challenging exercise and it's an
interior shot of the space all using
alien vegetation by the way so we tried
not to disturb the vegetation that was
natural to go to the landscape my next
project is a police station and this is
a project I my first enclosed building
which won an award and I'll tell you why
I won an award the police for various
historical reasons have occupied a very
contentious space in South Africa's
history they were often involved as an
instrument of the state to repress
people they were not trusted by anybody
and even I to this day I still have a
shiver down my spine when I see police
walking down the street regardless of
the nationality when when the police
contact me about making this police
station
I they said that we needed a place where
we could interact with the public and my
departure point was that i would say
that i would make the building not look
like a police station all this sounds
pretty simple up until this point police
stations had slot windows so that you
could fire out of them they had brown
brick walls so that you can't actually
see the dirt on them very defensive
strategies and in fact all of their
buildings all of their buildings were
fortresses in the landscape and I said
that one this building will actually be
fragile so I'm actually going to make it
white so that if if dirt shows up it
encourages you to clean it second I'm
going to remove all of the burglar bars
which it had on all of the windows and I
would have no fence at the front side
essentially I would I would turn the
inside of the the station out it and
make it a public sort of building the
success of this project is that it has
now informed a national strategy for how
all police stations should interact with
the area setting not necessarily the
form of the building per se but really
that the police stations can become part
of their context and can be can afford
to be ephemeral if an ephemeral and and
in that way show strength as opposed to
showing strength by having a
fortress-like sort of architecture the
staff in this building have loved the
building I go then visited often but the
most intriguing thing that one of the
most intriguing things was when I was
dealing with the police superintendent
and I was putting in hands growth taps
and so on in the in the in the bathrooms
the police superintendent said don't
give the police 9th a nice things they
will destroy them they're all animals
and I said if you treat your own staff
like animals and they will behave like
that and not only that they will go out
into the world and and take it out of
ordinary people so I said let's make a
building which brings dignity to the
police because they are a part of our
society and they need to see themselves
in a different light and this building
has been it's a fairly ordinary a sort
of architectural language but I think
it's quite a departure from the
normative way of how buildings were
designed in fact people are said to me
it looks like an art gallery it looks
like anything else and I said well I'm
pleased that the one thing it doesn't
look like is the stereotypical image of
what a police station needs to be the
little curved end over there was a
smokers corner and BBQ facility
a sort of place where the police would
get to rest and at the time there seemed
to be no necessity for this but it's one
of the most successful and simple spaces
in the whole project and I when last I
checked police people police persons
that is have been arguing quite a bit to
try and be relocated in that in a
particular station greenpoint state and
stadium is a project which i submitted
as part of a competition I was
shortlisted and what was interesting for
me about the stadium this is for the
World Cup was its potential in terms of
what it could offer society the local
society that is and what I did is pretty
much our hybrid concept so there was
relationship between the notion of tree
providing shelter again craft in terms
of beadwork but the location in terms of
a mountain sky see relationship and the
protea which is our national flower and
essentially the the design that that I
developed I worked on this with thumb
hok architects in London was the notion
of a very sort of again a delicate type
of structure but what was I think for me
that the main purpose of this of this
form is that you'll see the basket at
the base where the stadium was proposed
they were actually about 5,000 informal
traders who used to trade on that site
every Sunday so it was a means of
livelihood for them so my urban strategy
was to make a stadium around which these
the informal sector could still find a
place in other words this opportunity to
create infrastructure for 2010 did not
mean that we had to displace local
people local and and and disrupt the
local economy and I was actually quite
proud of the design for a that sort of
let's call it social purpose but also
the language of a stadium which doesn't
look like a typical stadium
unfortunately I didn't win it because I
was told the design was too radical I'm
sure you might have seen the current
stadium but I'm sorry to say that the
5,000 people who used to trade they're
no longer trade in that area and their
lives have been disrupted so again you
know this relationship between you know
what a building can do for its context
and it's sort of ethical responsibility
in terms of understanding its space
economy i think is lost on a lot of
people and I think it's
pity in a place like South Africa where
poverty is is almost endemic so it's
quite important to imagine how can
architecture help stave off these sort
of challenges I've also intervened in
other contexts this is a community
center Murray you actually saw this
building quite a quite a challenge in
context I was asked to make a community
center in Kyle each other and the first
problem that we had was that for years
and years the government of the day
would spend the least amount of money on
community centers just enough to get
votes and to keep the community quiet so
this project started out with the two
million Ryan budget and I made a very
strong and impassioned argument about
the role of buildings playing a role of
legacy and informing the context and
they they increase the budget to about
21 million which you know and it's not
that I was chasing fees but it was
really about putting enough investment
in the building which was really meant
to transform and support its context and
the strategy is also quite simple it's a
essentially a decorated shared a sort of
box but the whole one front facade
actually opens out onto the street so
that the relationship between building
and Street and public space has farmers
more potential than are closed also the
building the the language of the
building is uncompromisingly
contemporary they've been a number of
interventions in the so-called Township
context which have been very cynical and
very divisive and making arguments for
cheap buildings and I think it's quite
important that when one intervenes in
fragile contexts that architecture
should not replicate that fragility but
in fact that architecture should be a
refuge from the uncertainty of one's
context these are some of the interior
shots of the space for example the
gabion wall along that side uses a
particular stone which comes from table
mountain and table mountain is quite a
beautiful natural feature in our
landscape but why use table mountain
stone is that in that area people often
look at the mountain but they don't have
a chance to access it so it takes on a
sort of mythological dimension so I
actually had this idea of bringing the
mountain back to the people it's a you
know perhaps and a strange sort of idea
but the poetry of buildings can mean a
lot to peep
at times and that's a shot of it shoul
at the front with the openings you will
notice there are no roads accessing the
building which is one of mighty
frustrations about development in South
Africa said it's often very fragmented
the city of Cape Town could not agree to
put in a road so i made a building that
was literally standing in a in a field
of dust and these are the type of issues
when I talk about institutional growth
and development that's required because
you have government working in silos and
not talking to each other but this
building also has received a lot of
support and respect from the community
it's never been broken into it doesn't
have any burglar bars again and
interesting enough our showed a whole
range of buildings and told the
community will destroy the building you
need to protect it and this one has
managed to protect itself because it's
loved by other people and I'm actually
quite proud of that the autos project I
was selected to be involved in it and I
won't i won't dwell too much on this
except to say that for me the conceptual
conundrum was how does an African
architect intervene in inner mongolia
and what is an appropriate form of
language and response to to context do I
use this opportunity to further my
career and and do a signature sort of
building which is typical of what i
would do anywhere else or do I listen to
context I i took the latter approach and
i was particularly inspired by or rather
depressed by the extent to which
Beijing's develop into the last 10 to 20
years and in fact other parts of china
have really eroded the chinese
sensibility of urban form and
architecture they were very particular
let's call it hierarchy of public and
private spaces and I was intrigued by
this notion of a semi public space which
happens within the hutong sort of
courtyard dynamic so the building that I
essentially did was an assemblage of
three elements lying solid void
basically a series of cubes which
intellect me which interlock together to
form a semi-public space within the
heart of the building and really the
idea was it was to critique this notion
of Villa being in the middle of orders
and not
really interacting with its context but
making a building in which the innards
actually turned to the outside and it
was also highly informed by a lot of
mongolian mythology and we called it the
palace of the North I found a very
interesting Mongolian poem which takes a
whole month to recite and I analyzed the
poor women and abstract fitted into the
architectural form and I think this this
project was also quite intriguing
because it didn't affect the sort of
expectations that I was asked by certain
people in China about what type of
building would I make and the sort of
hot sort of references seemed to emerge
in these conversations and I said no I'm
not going to make a hut anyway so this
is a shot of that sort of sliver it's
called that Canyon between the two
buildings in which the public are drawn
into the internal space the next project
is a interesting for me because I was
asked to do a public transport office
building for government the brief was
for it to be the first sustainable
building for for the state but the
what's interesting is the actual tenant
we have a phenomena in South Africa of
commuter taxis which has a sort of semi
formal industry which is quite powerful
but also prone to violence and
constantly clashing with government and
similar to the police station the
government had always taken the attitude
that this committee taxi industry people
were where animals are not worthy of
being treated correctly and it caused a
lot of strife pretty much going back to
the 1980s so I made the argument that we
would again make a building in which a
taxi driver would feel that they
actually given respect and being a part
of the community so the language of the
building as opposed to what was there
before was deliberately contemporary
large volumes big spaces where if taxi
people had a debate and they wanted to
address the grievances that the Civic
architecture that was presented would
dignify the how those grievances are are
conveyed expressed and resolved and in
short it was it was I mean aside from
the sort of normative
let's call it technical issues about
making a sustainable building natural
ventilation looking at the heat gain and
heat loss in those sorts of mappings
this building was also specifically
located in a very poor area know if you
can see and see the context because
again government wanted to make the
message that they believe in people and
they want to actually respond to to the
to the needs of the township so it's
setting was quite important the height
was caught it was a big issue I mean
it's only seven stories but it's
actually the tallest building in the
area and a lot of the debates and
discussions that we were having with the
client being the premier of the state
was really about making a new type of
architecture that could help transform
this agenda of integrating the taxi
community without with within broader
society so the the materials and the
structures it's it's fairly simple it's
a series of boxes sort of tectonic
approached but I think really the for me
that the most important thing is just
its its its role in terms of really
responding to a sort of new interface
for a sector of society that has always
been on the on the periphery recently
I've been asked to do a museum for the
food and Allied Workers Union was
founded by a woman named Ray Alexander
Simons she moved to South Africa as a
teenager just just after world war one
and literally formed a trade union by
the age of 14 and in fact the the food
and Allied Workers Union was quite
instrumental in the 1980s in terms of
mobilizing people on the ground because
the ANC was banned so this this becomes
quite an interesting and significant
site of intervention because it's in
Google air too you might have heard in
the news about a killing of a tourist
that happened there a couple of weeks
ago so it's a fairly complicated site
and in fact before 1994 an American
activist amy biehl was also killed not
too far from from the actual project and
for me that the conceptual proposition
you was I interviewed a quite a famous
writer named and juggle and Evelyn about
township life and he told me that you
know growing on growing up in the
township everything works spatially in
sets of three so if you stayed in one
house the next three houses would be
your community and you were not you
would not walk beyond those three
streets because you would overlap with
another community and you get into
fistfights and so on but what he also
said was that you would have three sets
of three so whenever there was a
political or social issue communities
were organized in three sets of three
and so on and so forth so this this
number three became quite an interesting
let's say device so to speak with and
when I investigated the the type of
spaces that we couldn't have put in the
building this metaphor of almost a sort
of scale scale our approach to to to
reading this landscape became quite
important so essentially I'll actually
jump back to this image we've got the
museum component sitting over here but
in fact this is the whole sort of sight
there is a water feature over here which
is a detention pond where currently lots
of children drown every winter which is
our rainy season so the intervention
largely was okay to cycle back the
intervention was to create the museum
but also to rehabilitate this context
and you can begin to see the sort of
fragmented language of the informal
settlement and in some ways there's a
sort of dialogue between the formality
of the urban intervention along the side
versus the informality and end of the
sort of splicing of opportunities across
the space the the structure of the
building is essentially three
rectangular spaces which are interlocked
in volume they are structured according
to three in terms of height width and
depth the creation of a sculpture park
at the bottom scale over here this is
the existing building where relics and
assignments first held in initial
rallies and then a tower which forms a
visual beacon of the landscape which is
actually how you access the whole museum
complex by actually coming in from
underground the the project that right
now is really in its early stages I mean
this is an organization which has never
done a museum before so a lot of the
work is not necessarily the designing of
the building but understanding how to
structure a museum how to structure
curatorial practices what type of
institutional vehicle is appropriate and
structured fundraising and a lot of my
work is very much in that
domain because I've realized that it is
almost impossible to create architecture
unless one is engaged in some sort of
educational dynamic about what the site
can offer currently we proposed to the
city that this major street over here
which is one remedied where a media was
killed that this would be pedestrianised
the creation of a park along the side a
sort of empathy eter which would face
onto the building and that effectively
would have a sort of urban renewal node
the project was launched by the deputy
president I think about three months ago
so I'm hoping at the fundraising will go
well what I haven't heard much from them
at this particular point in time this is
some various you know initial schematic
renderings of the building which
essentially floats in the landscape and
creates this alternate terrain beneath
it Adam asters throne is a is a what I
call a provocation on occasion I think
it's quite important to do projects
which I meant to stimulate a bit of
debate and one of the debates that we
have in Cape Town is the issue of
appropriate height of buildings that the
argument behind this building was to
create a sort of an ecological tower
which would do serious investigations in
terms of wind changing in wind patterns
and and the rising of the sea level Adam
a stir by the way is it was a
mythological Greek god who apparently
lived at the top of Table Mountain and
prevented Portuguese ships from rounding
the Cape that's when the Cape change
from being called the Cape of storms to
the Cape of Good Hope apparently a
domestic was defeated when pathology
ideas went around so there's also a
tongue-in-cheek play on the origins of
Cape Town and add this sort of notion of
wind and colonization and development
this building is deliberately
provocative in relation to to its
context particularly because i think
it's it's sometimes important to
generate discussion and and be about
Miceli exemplary but to take a sort of
cutting-edge view in terms of what can
architecture represent and santino a
short on that side
apologies for them for the DPI level
them the other project that I just
wanted up is actually three more than
I'm almost at this project that I was
asked to do was quite an interesting one
we are beginning to introduce bus rapid
transit or what we call integrated rapid
transit in South Africa and I was asked
to put a proposal together for the
capital city and one of my key arguments
is that the installation of
infrastructure were there to stadium or
a police station etc can play a function
that is more than just the engineering
need of moving people from to and fro so
essentially the idea was plug-and-play
which is that all of these bus turbine I
would play a very particular function
depending on its context so for example
if in one area you find that there isn't
a clinic then a clinic would be attached
to the bus facility if another area you
found it there was a shortage of
libraries or other sorts of social
infrastructure that that would be
attached to the bus facility this
requires that your your bus stops are
actually on the side of the road as
opposed to the median and engineers
prefer the median because it's cheaper
because you have one structure serving
two sides but my arguments that then it
plays no urban function so it might cost
more to have two of the structures but
effectively it has a much more stronger
an impact so one of the LEDs are just
quick examples of what these could be I
mean this one was looking at adding an
ATM with a sort of sculpture park where
people could actually climb the an
inducer to run a mountain climbing sort
of training on the area charging of
electrical vehicles in a bicycle rack
and saying that these can play different
functions the sleeve took on a very
different notion way it was attached to
the library and also attached to a
potential sort of butterfly park because
one of these was located in a quite a
sensitive ecological area so all that
all the changes is essentially the the
scaffolding that wraps around the the
core structure is being the basic module
and it being expressed in this sort of
fashion or in that sort of way I must
mention that that project although it
received a lot of a claim from the
client because of its urban function
they indicated that it's not their
responsibility to solve urban issues
they just want to get people on buses so
for that reason
I did not succeed with the project but I
think it's quite telling that the level
of I would argue ignorance about how to
be strategic with investment and design
and capital Cape Town train station I
think is particularly one of the
projects when I think it speaks to this
issue the the real challenge of Cape
Town station i would say had had a lot
to do with its history stations and and
rail have had a very particular role to
play in the in the evolution of South
Africa in the sense that rail was used
as a colonial instrument to tame the
landscape in much the same way that the
opening up of the western United States
has an intimate relationship with rail
it was the same thing in South Africa so
we have this quite a famous image of
Cecil John Rhodes who was quite a famous
industrialist with this image of
connecting Cape Town to Cairo through
rail and from whom Zimbabwe was called
Rhodesia now for me this is interesting
because it shows the different roles
that the station has played historically
across time in the 1960s it was
redesigned and actually the the
president launched the building and said
it's a shining example of apartheid and
how we as a society need to live and
just to give you a sense of what that
was there was duplication of everything
there were double lifts in lowell is so
white people is for black people they
were trains for black people doing so
the whole infrastructure was duplicated
and what what i thought would be quite
interesting in terms of transforming the
station with regards to 2010 in a post
1994 sensibility was to was to look at
how do we make this place into something
special these are shots taken from the
1980s where protesters would run to the
station and in fact when i was doing the
designer interviewed people and found
that certain people actually even
tortured in the in the station so
although at a superficial level it's
just a building it has quite a charged
history with locals and its relationship
to its to its context was quite
problematic so this is essentially what
I inherited a site in which you couldn't
walk on the grass it was limited entry
into the building it was all about
control very poor lighting and it very
much treated as a sort of negative space
and it's right in the
to the city the crime levels on the
station were quite high but because
people don't have access to cars they
had no choice but to go through this
facility so they were a number of
challenges in terms of transforming the
project the first urban intervention was
fairly fairly mundane so to speak it's
really about reclaiming the relationship
between the city and at the station by
making a new sort of public space you
can see the value engineering that
popped in there so some of my detailing
is have obtained quite changed quite
drastically but what what's fascinating
for me about this project is that these
are shots of how the spaces use now and
it's been totally transformed from a
derelict spatial conditioned into one in
which people gather and have spontaneous
interactions and that's what interests
me about good architecture when it
creates the potential for new
interactions to emerge and when we had
our world cup event with the stadium in
the background there was a very
interesting dialogue between the station
and the stadium and we had the only fan
mile in the whole country where
literally the whole city came alive and
there were parties happening along the
route and particularly at the station
and this is a shot of an event that
happened at those in that same space
fairly recently and I saw this image
because I think it's such a sharp
contrast now it's become a place of
gathering a place of social interaction
a place of celebration whereas before it
was a place of oppression in a place of
negativity and the architectural
intervention in terms of materiality is
actually quite minimal it's just a few
key gestures about how do you define the
space internally I had a number of
challenges looking at particularly the
the way that the space was structured
there was poor lighting there were
informal traders all over the space so
visual access was quite difficult there
was no signage or advertising strategy
the space was not compliant in terms of
emergency evacuation so I had to develop
a design in which all of these sort of
problems could be dealt with and the
solution was quite simple open the
station up to the city changed the
glazing relocate the traders to a new
sort of trading market
but essentially again have a
relationship where as you come off from
the trains you can almost see the city
as soon as you arrive so again that your
sense of journey is that you don't get
off into a train into a dark space and
then back into the city but you have a
seamless transition and I think this is
probably one of the more successful
spaces in the city people actually come
to the station to linger you know
whereas before that was in the case
people have to get out the station as
quickly as possible they've had
photoshoots inside there they've had
people gathering hanging out and it's
without doing any major changes to the
overall skeleton or envelope the space
has become far much more amenable to to
being part of city life and I'd end up
and for me I mean if you know what this
was like for trust me you'd be as
excited as I am and we were able to
accommodate the the event also which is
also one of my specific briefs was to
make sure that we meet all the sort of
compliance conditions of 2010 informal
traders I showed you that sort of I'm
strange trading unit I designed a new
one that would be used within the the
main concourse it's essentially a sphere
that closes up and down this is partly
to do with the with the closing of sight
lines but also that when these are shut
that they also remain like pearls within
the concourse base so that you don't you
don't leave it to chance the way in
which informal trading begins to
interact within the main concourse and
on the station deck itself we had as you
can see quite an informal setting people
who trade and these are largely women
and one of the main problems is that
they would trade they would gather the
income but they had to walk quite a long
distance to get to an ATM so often
people who were mugged after work people
goods were often stall them because it
was just a trestle table and also the
rentals were quite high so what I
proposed I worked with an advertising
company we generated a model together
where we demonstrated that through
advertising because of the foot traffic
that you get to the station we would be
able to reduce the amount of capital
that the individual trader would have to
put into a trader unit and we decided to
make a sort of environment in which the
traders would be able to trade with more
dignity with storage security signage
and actually transform quite a day
ehrlich space into a new sort of public
realm this also went through quite an
extensive public participation process
with about 300 different traders and
numbers of presentations discussing and
workshopping the design intentions with
them so these drawings are not you know
the architect working in isolation but
there are processes letting form it and
then lastly at then what I call the XL
of the large scale I've been asked to do
a vision for Cape Town station of the
year 2013 my main brief was to to put in
the first underground in Cape Town so
where's I had a 2010 brief I was at a
2030 brief now one of the key debates
that we were having was how do you model
City in the year 2030 and given the fact
that most stations are refurbished on a
70-year cycle essentially the design
that i would put in now we'd need to be
robust until the year 2100 so the issue
of appropriate densities and particular
population perspective and the nature of
the economy and all these sorts of
things became quite critical because a
lot of the people in Cape Town were
quite comfortable with current densities
but you had we had to demonstrate that
the current densities are not only
unsustainable from from a causing
economic perspective but you need to
work with accurate forecasts to scale
this project so I developed the notion
of the meteo d transit oriented
development and applied it onto onto the
site minutes T 0 DS obviously it's a
international longest what that is but
this was also quite transformative
because for the first time they realized
that rail infrastructure is an
opportunity for housing is an
opportunity for urban densification so
whereas before rail was simply seen as
movement now it has sort of different
role and through a series of mappings
where I looked at historical urban
spaces looking at cycling routes and so
when I proposed a sort of new network
which effectively stitched the city
together because this piece of land
which is about fifty eight hectares
effectively divided the city into which
caused all sorts of implications in
terms of urban growth in urban
development and integrating it with
transport infrastructure sewage
utilities except sure was all part of
the brief and i managed to
with the densities that I predicted I
managed to squeeze in about 45 thousand
extra people into the city and what this
means is you remember before I spoke
about the sort of eccentric nature of
Cape Town with people on the periphery
and not in the core is that this was an
opportunity for people to have close
living in proximity to to where they
actually work so the project was not
just an exercise in a urban
densification but also had a sort of
poetic polemic dimension in terms of
bringing people previously displaced on
the city back into the CBD and this was
just a speculative sketch had done where
I'd sunk in the train station
underground with the Transport Museum
above on the actual actual site a very
early schematic shot of what it could
potentially be like in the underground
in we went through all the processes of
geotechnical issues etc and then these
are the sort of massing diagrams was
particular looking at to two phenomena
the one is the relationship of how wind
we change near 2013 because of climate
change so that began to influence the
form of the buildings and the more sort
of normative let's call it an urban
planning friendly massing model and over
the whole host of other permutations and
at that point
connected Cape Town is an integrated
mixed-use development that seamlessly
connects public transport modes serviced
by the full range of low carbon
intensive transport modes with the
particular emphasis on light tram and
electrical personal transport tailored
towards the needs of the pedestrian
connected Cape Town is to provide by its
iconic and vibrant central spine which
not only plays host to a real 24-hour
lifestyle but is a major contributor to
the biodiversity of CBD and offers a
range of historically informed public
spaces offering blend between culture
and public space making
boarding a train we enter the health and
wellness precinct neighborhood Dean
housing a fitness park a public swimming
pool and squash and tennis courts this
precinct offers residents an opportunity
to care for their bodies and well-being
as easily as they would their economic
well-being clinics and health care
centers are complemented by open spaces
a research center as well as
high-density housing this creates
individuals and communities at work and
at leisure who are informed by value
system of mutual respect and human
solidarity using the many forms of
sustainable pedestrian friendly
transport available on the site one
enters neighborhood scene dedicated as a
service precinct neighborhood see offers
government services and social services
such as paying municipal bonds and
daycare in kindergarten respectively
beautiful recreational spaces and
government staff housing make
neighborhood see a friendly relaxing and
efficient destination as we move into
neighborhood be we enter a site of
innovative technical research and
education the spirit of the entrepreneur
thrives here with restaurants cafes
stores of food market and various forms
of micro industry complemented by a fire
station and a Resource Center
neighborhood B is an incubator of
economic and technological advancement
neighborhood a which lies at the heart
of the CBD houses a cultural center a
museum and art gallery and a Memorial
Park in line with emphasizing the
heritage significance of the site
the neighborhood is also home to the
Department of Home Affairs a South
African Police Service Law ports
financial service institutions as well
as high-density urban housing the
seamless integration of the precincts
underpinned by various and diverse
transport modes serves as a connection
between our past and our future a
connection between mountain and see a
connection between rich and poor a
connection of ideas and dreams it is a
place for all leading the way in an
equitable Cape Town adjust Cape Town a
vibrant Cape Town welcome to connected
Cape Town
just just one caveat the that commission
was essentially an urban planning
presentation it wasn't in architectural
projects with architectural resolution
is deliberately ambiguous it was more
about the sort of Planning and
infrastructure approaches to the site
is that a good or a bad thing oh I have
a very specific question when you were
talking about the police station and
when he said that they would break the
faucet yes how do you convince the
client or in this case the head of the
police who actually knows so much about
his kind of his force that no this is a
good thing and it will change how does
that conversation kind of take place and
how do you convince someone like that
that no this is not actually the best
thing but you know fortunately the
president is always a good device I mean
we Loretta did a very good police
station i think it was in the early 90s
and i did the argument that i that i
made was basically humanist in social
one you know if we continue to to to be
pessimistic in cynical about the human
condition then we will only replicate
those type of behaviors so i was making
an argument that even the smallest thing
such as the type of force that you put
in a bathroom a door handle the color of
a wall can assist transforming the
assistant let stress the word assist
assistant transforming how people behave
in space I was also fortunate in that
the police themselves were very much
interested in transforming their
perception in society no they stopped
being a force they became a service they
wanted to be seen as friendly they had
lots of commercials on TV and I told
them that you know you can have the
marketing image of of being a service
but you need to translate that into
concrete actions about how do you behave
yourselves you know they mean and that
goes right out how do you plan a
building where do you put to the
superintendent's office when you put the
mess hall where do you put the smoking
area where you put the the cells all of
those type of decisions can reinforce a
new way of being for for the police and
at the end of the day it's also just
being dogmatic and and explaining your
point through through different to
different arguments you can't just be
emotional eater president
to have research but you must also have
conviction because if you're unsure of
what you're trying to do people will not
pay you to do it over here you mentioned
you mentioned twice and to your projects
that the external people from different
parts of the world didn't think or
thought of a certain African aesthetic
but we say the sharpest difference
between the internal Africa African
except aesthetic is versus the world
view of it but first off I think the
notion of an African aesthetic is a
contentious idea Africa's far too large
and far too complex that's why i said in
my paper that that simplistic readings
about what is an appropriate african
aesthetic wall will fail because we have
examples of modernity we have examples
of contemporary work we have huts we
have the pyramids in egypt so i think
it's more important to talk about the
type of field of relationships that are
set up by by architecture as the form of
the aesthetic so my buildings are very
much predicated on how they influence
how people behave whether it looks
modernist or it looks curved you know
for me the aesthetic is the aesthetic of
human interaction now contrast that with
like the the trophy for example where I
consciously made a form which did not
look like a form which was African but
it could have come from any place but I
think they're the sort of once you would
I mean the way that i sculpted it it was
very much very different to the sort of
rectilinear and structured and sort of
precise geometries of a typical typical
trophy I have been asked in many forums
about what is inappropriate
architectural and which in aesthetic and
what can that be and I admit that you
know my subjectivity my training my
background perhaps colors my particular
perception of what that is but I'm far
much more interested in architecture in
which responds to do contextual needs
and sometimes those needs are not form
related but their culture related the
institution related
are socially related and how can
architecture play more than being an
enclosure but actually become a
catalytic intervention point and
sometimes like for example in the Cape
Town station forecourt the architecture
is almost absent but it makes a space
which is entirely different than what it
was for the last 40 years
this might be related to Christmas
question in some way
there seems to be a tendency I think
we're at least what I've seen some
student projects to glamorize the
informal maybe even coming from the city
and here I see you to some extent a
desire to you may be released from it or
to change to something formal and if it
struck me that there was the question is
how do you maintain either that balance
and in the balance between the informal
form or even desired anymore it's a very
good question because it goes to the
heart of lots of our urban and
architectural discussions in cape town
in the country in general by my i have
my father's sister or cousin rather has
been an informal trader for 40 years and
she'd be at the sidewalk selling
beetroots and she's actually trapped in
a very particular economic cycle i think
it's very easy for us to take the
liberal position and to romanticize the
trader on the sidewalk who is being who
has ingenuity in terms of how they are
navigating the city and surviving the
fact of the matter is that nobody really
wants to survive everybody wants to
thrive so what I did with with
particularly those spaces that I did
what's called an economic progression
model where I structured the sequence of
spaces so that you could have an
emerging trader so to speak who might
get you know a 1 by 1 square metre place
but then they would then graduate to a 2
by 2 2 a 4 by 4 and then you actually
set conditional limits for how long
somebody can occupy a particular space
so that you've encouraged the
progression I don't have an aversion to
to the formalization of informal context
as long as it's done with sensitivity
and i'm also not keen on gentrification
in its in its and it's in its brutal
form but i also have a lot of caution
about romanticizing poverty and
romanticizing the native and going
through the township and saying this is
so cool and then freezing those people i
use those deliberately in a form of
suspended animation in which we
glamorize the township and i stand in
the minority on that because many people
will talk about how sexy the township is
and let's keep it as it is but they
would never stay there
to estebans question about this
relationship between the formal and the
formal what struck me about your
projects is the degree to which they are
all essentially interventions and the
formation of a kind of or remaking
literally of a public sphere of an
introduction of a public sphere for an
emerging nation essentially and you
talked about South Africa's as you know
as as a developing nation and the desire
for a level of humanity within that but
i was wondering like how in your
projects do you negotiate that pressure
to maybe private development and
privatization and neoliberalism within
you know a country that clearly is very
you know industrialized and there's a
global banking concern and and so how
what is that balance between you know
let's say that informal economy in the
formal economy that exists that's
already it's some respects globalize I
mean I I don't have many private clients
and you forcing it up front but my
people know me as working in sort of
social space but i but i make an
argument that just because i'm working
in the social space it doesn't mean the
architecture it doesn't have to be
sophisticated in advanced my i also
write in the k times about this sort of
issue about how to mediate of courses of
of commerce which can be quite brutal in
South Africa and in that we have really
wealthy people and places of incredible
access and it's very easy to to lose
one's ethics and participate in that
world and ignore the huge sway that is
around oneself i I don't I wouldn't say
that I found a balance in my practice as
yet a lot of my work some of them I hit
on this I think they're their
experiments their ideas which are
incomplete and I look back on and they
haven't worked but i think the as much
as much as clients choose you I think
the architect also has the right to
think how they choose their clients and
the type of work that they do and I
think that would reduce a lot of the
conflict on Cape Town station in
particular it was a very difficult
project because you know at first we
started with a sort of social
intervention it was a government project
and they were very keen on all the ideas
and then the minister made this
statement about all of the train
infrastructure
pay for themselves so overnight the the
social dynamics certainly switched to a
very commercial dynamic in fact this
presentation you'll notice it out I
deliberately dropped in words about
cultural I never spoke about the offices
that need to be there because I was
trying to provoke the client into
understanding their their cultural
social responsibility can balance ever
be found i I don't know i mean you come
to south africa at some point the the
differences are so stark that sometimes
the only way to try and find balance is
to is to swing at the opposite end and
do you do your damnedest to be as as as
as much as a counterpoint to to the
current pavillion condition
you mentioned here and also with the
students that South Africa's our
variables with a young country and we're
working in Johannesburg and you also
sort of talked about the city trying to
come to terms with what it should be in
terms of going forward and so for
example at the recent World Expo the I
think the theme was better city better
life and perhaps it's the image of
modernity in contrast perhaps with your
sort of thesis about relationships of
how how do you think that you negotiate
the condition between what the image of
the city should be thinking about the
tower that you showed with your thesis
about aesthetics and actually being
concerned more about the aesthetics of
relationships rather than the aesthetics
of the image sure I mean um me talking
about the world expo because actually
delivered a lecture there and I was
actually quite struck because they were
think was a discord between the feeling
of the event and the content that will
show there it's it's quite it's quite a
quite a difficult one because I do
believe that one can talk about
aesthetics and ethics it into the
interchangeable sort of way I mean if
you think of it can stand and so on that
the way that you make your your
buildings and how they look represents
tactically your your values and what
they are but I think in a lot of my
project some of them quite frankly our
tongue in cheek because it's very much
about that pendulum and just providing a
counterpoint that when the buildings are
actually manifest for example the police
station and the community center and so
on I mentioned this notion about a bold
humility and a sort of selfless
disregard those projects are very
different to the unbuilt projects which
are almost experiments as it were you
know and ways of just trying to push the
boundaries this notion of balance is
something that if I can just just expand
I mean it I I'm intrigued you know we're
taught to think of balance and we're
taught to think of this and the
architects were finding a middle road
but I more and more that I've interacted
with architecture I think balance is
almost impossible the forces of one
particular client and context always
conspire to make a project skewed in one
direction or the other and I think
balance should beings received more how
does how does this relate into something
else so for example the tower is not so
much about its aesthetic form on its own
but the tower in dialogue with the
mountain and the city in between and
that type of sort of tension because
seen on its own I'm not really convinced
that it would be our that that
particularly effective in terms of the
studio approaching about about young
people and trying to find an appropriate
aesthetic I've taken a very personal
position about what i call the aesthetic
of human relationships I think the the
role of the agent or the author in terms
of being authentic to oneself about what
is one's position is probably more
important to me than the actual outcome
we need in we have a youth in South
Africa that have been demoralized have
no sense of self-confidence who are
always trying to find easy answers and
trying to be something else than what
they are in order to be and I look at my
work as an example to say to people you
can be whatever you want to be and just
put it out there and let the world
absorb it and reflect so what I what I
would say to to our students particular
issue handlers Burke and so on and how
to intervene in a very foreign context I
think it's I think it's critical to to
to read the context as best as one
possibly can but to bring one
subjectivity to the table and let it be
confronted by by difference and so on
all right that partly answers what you
saying
I'm have a question about the last the
last project the 20 31 yeah because
that's an incredible new density for for
Cape Town yes sir yeah and over here it
looks you know look very very low
normative you know it's it's it's quite
radical yeah yeah so I'm curious about
the response to that and also in
relation to something I should know more
about a kind of lost track of what
happened with the right to a house but
you know what South Africa change and I
know that has been sort of hugely
controversial especially since all those
houses were so little houses and
wilshire right and so the polemics of
your new project in relation to what's
happened with the right to housing and
whether that's succeeded or failed in
any way the 2030 project is very
controversial for those very reasons
because you see a lot of the urban
planning paradigm is about three storey
dwellings and so on but if you actually
map the potential density of the CBD
according to that versus a strong and
vibrant economy we should be looking at
both these like buildings of average
seven to ten stories except etc so what
we have is the sort of conundrum where
people like the waist cape town looks
now but they don't understand the
economic implications of freezing
development in its current form you'll
also see that on the diagram the
buildings are farmers closer than
average because the research that we've
shown is that with climate change coming
in wind and the Sun is going to get far
much stronger so we're going to have a
climate which requires buildings that
are much closer together in the future
then they are currently now and that
also was a point of contention because
everybody wanted the wide sort of
rolling ramblas boulevards and I was
like listen look at the climate and
again responding to context on the issue
of housing last year I was appointed the
only architect i'm going to pointed the
advisor to the national minister of
housing and we've had long discussions
about this issue of the right to housing
versus the writer houses
and the proposal that I put to him is
that he needs to at some point either in
2012 or in 2014 because the agency has
to make a decision on this they need to
actually start engaging the public in
explaining that this simply isn't enough
viscous or capital to maintain this
culture of everybody getting their house
and that a new type of urbanism needs to
evolve and i've argued that the
government should be involved in mid
what i call incubator housing
opportunities again create rental stock
you can stay in it for four to five
years and then you should be encouraged
to move on so that young people can come
in and and that's that's quite a big
political debate because of the promise
of 1994 everybody gets a house and this
but the reality is that again the
numbers are not pointing in the am i
pointing to the current status quo is
being sustainable but you're absolutely
correct the first project has been quite
interestingly controversial for a number
of reasons
that program still still continues but
what's interesting is I'm doing some
research and I'm increasingly getting
data where young people are saying
because they want to pursue jobs they
need to be mobile and if you're if
you're given a house that actually
restricts the ability for you to move so
if you want an innovative country to
develop you should make your country as
of city as flexible as possible for
people between the ages of 18 and 33 and
not try to tie them down to a fixed
asset you know whereas before the notion
was everybody wants a house and so on
and you find the jobs they also can and
I think that in the in the world view
and the logic of government which is a
different generation they don't
understand the fluidity of how
innovative and knowledge oriented
markets work in the need to be able to
move to go to different cities and not
be tied down with an asset okay thank
you apologize if it is a bit long
thank you